journalists now for the most part are
one paycheck away from living on the
street this is true their only hope is
to go Mega viral so they have to write
these crazy articles like American white
male meltdown starts with Taylor Swift
and ends with Justin mode so they
basically have to be like if you don't
like Taylor Swift or you criticize her
or you say that maybe she shouldn't pick
our president you're you're almost at
the phase where you're going to start
decapitating members of your own family
you just don't know it yet the way that
they tried to beat Trump last time was
to basically say everyone who's voting
for him or who's even thinking of voting
for him is a Neo-Nazi militia member but
they don't know it yet they don't know
it yet it's not it's stage one or
whatever it's not detectable but if we
ran all the tests if we did all the
Diagnostics we would find out that they
are card carrying members of the
American Nazi party